okay
hi Russia
I think we're live now
and
I call Yani I see you
everybody's joining
um
Russia why don't you ask the folks where
they're from
oh yeah uh so uh where are you uh from
folks like uh can you just put it on
chat would love to know where are you
from so I am from Bangalore India and my
name is Russia I'll be your host for the
session and also weekly extort has also
joined us for the session here also will
be helping me uh with the session uh
yeah hi I'm in uh I'm in San Francisco
California
I see other folks also joining in I
would love to know where are your folks
from you can just put down uh where are
you from on the chat here let me just do
one thing let me just put my
introduction here in case uh you don't
know me so I am from Bangalore India
happy to see you folks
Andrew where are you joining us from by
the way
so I'm joining hi everybody I'm Andy I'm
uh one of the uh instructors for simple
learn and I am actually from Portugal
oh nice
so
it's one of the wonderful things about
the simply learn is that it has a global
global reach a global audience and a
global
um faculty so
okay yes uh so today's session is about
dialectic com Cloud committing broadcast
I can see uh folks are still joining in
uh meanwhile uh we can maybe just talk
over chat and uh have a conversation
where I can see people have started
talking on chart all three
all right
it's almost time
yep
we're just few minutes away from
starting the session uh so we'll just
wait for folks to join in and uh yes yes
love that energy
is like full on you know like replying
talking that's really amazing
nice to meet you
okay I can see folks joining in uh so
folks would love to know uh meanwhile
other folks are also joining your
starter session in few a few minutes
would love to know uh where you uh are
from and you can reply in the chat here
we can just have a conversation before
you know we start the session so we
already have our speaker with us Andy
Lewis and also uh my fellow colleague
Stuart is also here uh for driving the
session and my name is Russia I will be
the host of this session I'll be helping
you uh with the session as well so I can
see folks are joining in uh
I can see like
someone from Sri Lanka Sri Lanka that's
nice
hey Kumar
well while we're waiting I could tell
you that it is a very very hot day here
in Portugal today very sunny beautiful
beach day hope you guys are having the
same
yeah here in California it's
a sunny summer weather
the funny story about the part of
California I live in
um where in August because of the way
the air comes off of the ocean it can
get quite cold in the evenings
the famous American writer Mark Twain
once said
the coldest winter I ever spent was
summer in San Francisco
wow
I think we're ready to start Russia so
move
awesome uh so yeah let me uh just start
so uh so folks we'll be talking about
the program review of caltex uh Cloud
committing boot camp and how basically
it will set your the stage for your big
career in between uh so before before we
start I would love to know like where
your folks are from you can introduce
yourself to a chat here so I'm Russia
I'll be your host and I'm from India
Orlando uh we also have uh my colleague
Steward here with us uh and uh where are
you from Stuart
uh San Francisco California
area I'd live on the other side of the
Bay
awesome
[Music]
I know we also have a speaker here with
us Andy Lewis Andy where are you from
so I am actually from Portugal so
um in Europe
oh awesome uh folks who are joining
right now you can introduce yourselves
on the chat you can tell us where you're
from and have a conversation on chat
with folks here uh meanwhile I'll just
uh start the session uh so before we
start I'll just uh
I'll just uh set a few ground rules here
uh so uh you can put the questions in
the Q a box here uh because if you put
it over chat it will actually get lost
and we get a lot of messages over chat
here so it'll be very nice if you can
put it on the Q a box and I'll make sure
we take up those questions you know
towards the end or in between the
session then when we get that so let me
know if you are confused about how to
put the questions on the Q a part you'll
see a q a uh button here on your if
you're joined free mobile auto you will
see the Q a section in your screen and
you can just go and add a question there
second uh the session is being recorded
so you can expect a follow-up mail with
recording link and a bonus offer as well
to request a proof of attendance for
this webinar enter your name in the post
webinar services
sorry
also uh today's agenda uh is basically
about you we'll we would love to know
you and uh we will be talking about
cloud computing careers uh also how
caltex ctma actually will be helping you
in your career you know get ahead in
your career and also we'll be talking
about learner outcomes enrollment steps
and bonus offer towards the end of the
session and also uh we'll be taking up
the Q a sections which I told you about
so feel free go and put your q a uh you
know questions on the Q a section and uh
we'll make sure to take up those
questions
also uh
let's
uh so I would love to know more about
you so how much experience do you have
so uh are you currently studying uh do
you have like zero to three years of
experience just started off or are you
been professional of three to five years
experience or uh you have more than five
years of experience so you can just
quickly uh share
you well how much experience do you have
uh on the screen you can see your
question popping up and you can select
an option which basically suits your
experience and uh submitted
I can see folks are already uh you know
voting in uh I can see uh one third of
the folks are currently studying and uh
okay okay more more what's coming in uh
okay I'll be closing the poll in 15
seconds
okay I can see
uh I think 20 of the folks have zero to
three years of experience I can see
almost 70 folks have more than uh five
years of experience that's great so we
have basically a diversity of audience
here you know
it's really good to have
awesome I can see more folks
are still voting but I'll be closing the
poll in five seconds so please you can
see the poll on your screen uh you can
select the options and uh you know
submit it
and I can see folks who are in the
starting of their career also uh seven
percent of them
uh
okay I've shared the results uh now
moving on uh to
uh simply run so basically simplier is
the world's number one online bootcamp
uh here we have 13 years of experience
in digital skills training and we have
trained over 5 million of professionals
over in 150 countries uh like as we all
know that we have gone through a very
rapid digital transformation and during
lockdown and having these digital skills
is more essential than ever uh are we
really uh proud of basically proud to
help you out with that and uh we are
really proud to be the delivery partner
for Caltech as well
uh before before I move forward with the
program and uh obviously uh you know we
will be taking your questions as well I
would like to introduce you to Andy
Lewis who is our speaker for for this
particular event and Andy would love to
know more about you can you please
introduce yourself
sure hi everybody my name is Andy Lewis
and I am one of the uh AWS instructors
for the boot camp that uh you'll
possibly be joining uh with simply learn
so I have my own Consulting and um
practice called try on the IT services
and I hold several
certifications spanning from java
development
containerization with Docker cloud
computing
and so I find that I use that in my
practice quite a bit and I also do
Consulting in the Aerospace industry and
do teaching as well so I do all these
things together which gives me a good
synergistic effect to teach students in
the classroom and also bring back the
lessons I've learned in a production
environment on what actually works and
what doesn't
and I've been teaching for simply learn
for a couple of years now
and I've been really enjoying especially
the Caltech program since it brings
together so many people from diverse
backgrounds and I find the people who do
join the program are extremely
interested in the subject matter which
is uh which is a joy to teach to those
kind of people so hopefully I'll see you
in the following course
uh great thank you so much for the
introduction angry uh just curious to
know uh like the cloud computing uh
world has evolved during the pandemic
and uh in the last few years how do you
think it has impacted us
I'm sorry uh can you just please repeat
that because I was reading a uh a chat
there I thought it was redirected to me
you were asking
yeah sure uh so I was seeing the fact
that cloud is the black backbone of the
economy uh could we have survived the
pandemic and the ships from
working from home and no contact
ordering stuffs in you know and all
other changes we have gone through if we
didn't have Cloud uh but cloud computing
has evolved in the last few years like
how do you think it has impacted you
know us
well I think that during the pandemic uh
for sure Cloud was a great facilitator
and Expediting uh you know the the
amount of time that was necessary to get
everything up and running the
infrastructure was already there to take
advantage of so businesses in a very
short amount of time were able to uh
provision all the infrastructure and the
software needed to get their employees
to connect from their homes
to the online services
would they have been able to do it
without cloud of course eventually yes
but this would have taken a lot more
time effort and the problem is is
the effort they couldn't bring their
employees in to set up the hardware
so it was a little bit of a catch-22
even if they did have even if they did
say hey let's take a month and a half to
do this they weren't you know legally
able to come in so uh having this in the
cloud you know greatly facilitated that
since it was just about you know giving
a credit card and uh and hooking into
these Services right
uh in terms of How It's evolved since
then I think uh much like everybody uh
kind of adopted Netflix over the
pandemic lots of people just adopted
cloud computing and said you know what
let's let's actually go down this route
this is actually a good route for us to
explore more of our services maybe let's
take a look at doing some lifting and
shifting of some databases or some
compute resources uh that we have on
premise and let's just Port that over
the cloud so there's many many
advantages to the cloud but I think for
sure like you you stated the pandemic
was a catalyst towards that
yeah Andy you just mentioned Netflix and
and isn't that a classic example of how
cloud computing technology enabled
um new business models to kind of take
over and disrupt old ones and
change absolutely right
yeah that's a that's a great Point
Storage so Netflix is uh all in with AWS
right they're one of the
um
kind of go-to companies to emulate when
you want to
possibly do something similar right and
there's a lot of white papers online and
how to's and guides how Netflix is
actually doing things and in the AWS
space official documentation that's
available in AWS on how they do things
amongst other companies of course but
they're one of those Flagship companies
that kind of you know spearheaded the
way to AWS one of those big names
and as you mentioned you know the the
environment we're in now is if somebody
who has an idea wants to start a an
online business
they don't have to invest
thousands or even millions of dollars in
infrastructure they can
like you said use their credit card set
up an AWS or Azure account and
um pretty much provision everything they
need to get online
quickly and exactly expensively
exactly it becomes like a new utility
bill just like we all have our utility
bills and our everyday lives like for
electricity or perhaps water wherever
you you know some people don't pay for
water but like say I pay for water in
Europe uh right it becomes another
utility bill where you only pay for what
you use right so if you only put the
lights on in your house during the day
right well you'll only pay for the
amount use of electricity during the day
right not at night it's the same thing
for all the machines and the databases
or whatever traffic is Flowing you only
pay for what you use on the cloud which
is a real bonus because your your cost
of ownership goes goes drastically down
there's no upfront Capital costs like
you're mentioning Steward you don't have
to invest in hundreds of thousands of
dollars to build you know all these data
centers you can just basically pay as
you go
it's a it's a fantastic new world that
we live in and
this is an opportunity to get into it
you can see the the numbers here talk
about
how big the the field is in the the rate
of growth so
let's move on
I can see yeah uh so thank you so much
to it and Andy uh so Annie I just wanted
to know that uh these cloud computing
skills uh they open many career Parts uh
but I can see that it is pretty vast you
know in terms of career what you can
take up it's not really limited to you
know uh cloud computing it has a lot of
many categories and varieties where uh
you can go uh and basically boost your
career head towards it so what do you
think about that
well the nice thing is is that a lot of
the roles that you find on premise in
the data centers that you know that
companies have of course you have people
that are specialized in specific areas
you have people that are Architects you
have people that are developers uh you
have people that are network Engineers
or security Specialists and so that kind
of translates as well in the cloud
um where we do have architectural roles
like the cloud architect you see here as
the first point on the top
and that is usually the one that people
navigate to as a kind of a first attempt
right because that really helps you
master the other ones if that's what you
want to do as well if you want to become
let's say a cloud engineer later on and
Cloud engineer more has to do with
monitoring the real-time systems setting
alarms looking at metrics making sure
that everything is running smoothly uh
performing updates to the system all
that kind of stuff a lot of those other
certifications will rely on a core set
of knowledge that's set forth by the
cloud architect so the cloud architect
again is really setting up the
infrastructure listening to what the
customer
uh needs right listening to the business
needs of the stakeholders uh figuring
out what services need to be in play in
order to satisfy whatever requirements
are put on the table now of course if
you're a developer a Java developer a
python developer whatever you're going
to be interested in how do I develop in
the cloud that's going to be different
too there's a whole slew of tools there
dealing with continuous integration
continuous deployment you have things
like serverless
services that are available to us and so
you would gain
Advantage by going to the cloud
developer certification as well right so
it'll depend what you already do and if
you don't do presently nothing because
you're completely new as you said we had
various backgrounds here that uh was
clear in the poll uh then I would
recommend that everybody go towards the
card architect as a first step and then
you'll know oh I like this part better
or that part better and these three
bullets on the right hand side
the cloud database administrator the
cloud security engineer and the cloud
devops engineer those are more advanced
and specialized certifications that you
can navigate to after you go through the
Clark architect or the cloud engineer or
the cloud developer
something that is required for sure
yeah you'll see these certifications in
general and this is this is a standard
across all the IT industry usually
certifications will expire between two
to three years you know every vendor is
a little bit different every
certificate's a little bit different and
so you know this is outside the scope of
uh of Simply learn but uh you know it's
a it's it's everybody's
due diligence to keep up with uh the
changes in the industry right what you
know today guaranteed in three years
from now there's going to be a good 20
30 percent that's different so you have
to you know keep up in the industry just
like if you were a developer uh you know
new languages come out right and new
versions new features come out as well
so it's a constantly evolving field but
the good thing is is once you get into
the cloud
you're always going to have a job in the
car because the cloud is not going to go
away it's just it's massive everybody's
using it it's the new thing and that's
what's helping us scale everything
globally and so it's an extremely secure
uh technology
uh to have knowledge in for you know
your future
um we had a question in the chat just
came in
um can you
do a brief thumbnail recap of the
difference between Cloud architect Cloud
engineering Cloud developer sure so
Cloud architect is about identifying the
services and identifying you know how to
how to create a system that will scale
that will be false tolerance those kind
of things how did
dispatch that either regionally globally
not that caught architect the cloud
Engineers everything's usually in place
right the system is running and now
there's updates that need to be made we
need to monitor this in real time are
there any alarms do I need to be
proactive do I need to automate a
response to an alarm these are Cloud
Engineers they're basically
usually working on shifts right 24 7.
those kind of Engineers and the cloud
developer is is really a specific role
where you might be a Java developer and
you need to develop your company's web
application right and so you need to
know the tools and the processes in
place to automate and improve the
quality of your software either through
like I said a CI CD pipeline continuous
integration continuous development
Pipeline and then the cloud engineer
would take your
um your artifact your deployments
artifact and would put it on the system
for you so it's kind of a layered
approach where you would have the cloud
architecture setting up the
infrastructure the cloud engineer making
sure it's running smoothly in real time
and the cloud developer developing in
Tandem and giving the cloud engineer new
releases of its software every so often
great thank you for that
okay uh Russia I think we can
uh before we move on we actually got one
more question I think uh Stuart has
already answered uh the this course will
be self-paced or interactive online
classes I as well as ask this question
so uh let me just uh like you know like
tell you like uh so the course is based
on live classes and it includes a
self-based material so preparing for the
class sessions as well as live
integrated lab environment to let you do
exercises and projects on the system
so I hope that answers your question and
I can see until replying I'm asking like
if we have to practice will you provide
the lab resources yeah we're going to
get into that in the next part of the
presentation so we'll yeah we are
fortunate that Andy is here to show us
what that live environment looks like
so
in the meantime
did these salary look right to you Andy
these are things we took off of
Glassdoor as as the averages across the
U.S
yeah I I would look more like obviously
at the average there because based on
the polls yeah the answers of the polls
there uh of course the higher ends those
are for you know uh Engineers that would
have uh you know several years
experience there but
um you know
I can I can tell you that yes those
those seem to be the cloud Developers
for whatever reason I'm a developer so
I'm a little bit sad to see that we're
getting paid less than than the rest
but I'm also an architect and I look at
the jobs like every day I get uh I get
um
emails from LinkedIn every day on jobs
and I could tell you that yes the the
architectural uh positions aren't about
that range uh I lost actually the slide
there uh for whatever reason I think
Russia had a zoom issue so uh okay I'll
try to get the slides up from my side as
well yeah but yeah the from the numbers
I I remember there the um
the only reason the engineer maybe the
the cloud engineer is a little bit
higher is because you know you're more
working on shift and you're probably
going to be you know doing some uh
possibly some night shifts so it might
be some premiums in there for your uh
for your extra sleep deprived uh you
know position but uh the cloud architect
is a sweet spot where you know you're
gonna make a very good amount of money
even on an entry level
that's uh that's a good thing to know
and and it's interesting that you talked
about that as being an entry point into
you know the first set of skills that
you should learn in cloud computing
skills around the architect role
oh yeah it'll make you way better in
every other aspect uh that for me is a
is a foundational
um you know material and we do go
through all of it in the simply learn
program
so
so bear with me for a moment as I get
the uh the slides back up
there we go
get to the right place in the
presentation
I was just going to ask um about the
kinds of skills that
someone needs to have in order to
Be an Effective professional in cloud
computing
and I interrupt in the middle of a
thought so what were you about to say
I was just looking at
um
a question in the chat here and it said
what are the top five texts that are
growing alongside the cloud
uh well I mean I I mean I don't have a
definitive answer but I know that right
now ai machine learning Big Data uh you
know those those come to mind right now
those are kind of uh everywhere uh there
has been a little bit of movement
movement also in the containerization
space
uh specifically in um in in Docker
there's been some new technology that's
been you know created there that's
that's creating a buzz but
um other than that I mean you know it's
it's just basically all those services
are also
um
are also available within the cloud
right so you don't think cloud is not by
itself just a single technology it is an
ocean that encompasses and manages all
the technologies that you'll find out
there so if there is a new technology
that came out uh you know you can
incorporate it in the cloud very very
easily
right it's not they're not exclusive
um give me just a moment while I sure
and just while we're waiting here we
have a question and answer saying I am
a.net developer should I learn Azure on
AWS uh Azure or to AWS excuse me now.net
is supported in AWS as well there's lots
of support for Net10 AWS so you're you
know of course if you're more of a
Microsoft shop right
um then who else better than Azure right
they are Microsoft right so uh of course
if you're a DOT net slash Windows shop I
would go more with Azure because they
have more integration with active
directory and all those kind of
Microsoft products but if you want to
stay in AWS
um dot net is is very well supportive as
well
yeah one moment I'll be right there
just pulling up the slides
one of the things about the zoom
platform is it does some weird things
sometimes when you're sharing your
screen
yeah so it just under there was an
anonymous attendee that asked also in
their question and answer what job roles
can I apply to after the program and is
their support with job hunting from
simpler and more importantly candidates
in Canada well I get that you can apply
for the um AWS architect positions and
I'll let Stewart or
um
we are going to be talking about uh
the job assist program
with yeah simply learn which is
something that extends after you earn
your certificate and gives you access to
uh services that will help you with your
job search we don't have a job placement
or job guarantee program but we do offer
services that will help you
um present yourself better during your
job search and be able to find
great opportunity among all those those
that are out there so here we are at LNG
we finally got it back up I apologize
for that
um you need up-to-date skills to become
a proud practitioner
um why is it important for someone to
have
familiarity with all these different
aspects
while all of all of these aspects are
important to every company right so for
example here let's just take some random
points here the last one on the right
Disaster Recovery uh you know who
doesn't want to be prepared for the day
that you know uh your databases go down
or you lose uh a data center right these
are the same issues that you would have
on premise right now when you go to
cloud of course now we're dealing with
data centers that belong to AWS or Azure
and so they're not immune to you know
failures as well right of course they
have a whole bunch of redundancy in
place that you may not have had on print
but
it is still possible for a data center
to go down and so
um you either rely on that built-in
redundancy and other times you want to
build upon it and you have to know
if the whole region of you know Nord
Virginia went down can I automatically
and seamlessly run my applications in
London right can you do that yeah you
can do that but you have to set this up
okay when it's across regions or cross
continents let's say so this is very
important because you don't want to lose
customer confidence uh you don't want to
lose money right every hour that you go
down how much money does that translate
to who knows that's that's business
specific right that would be just one
aspect of it the other one let's say
Auto scaling here on the on the right
hand side all the way at the bottom
Auto scaling if you have more users
that are solicitating your sites that's
great but can you handle that that's
traditionally a huge pain point with
on-premise data centers because you may
not have enough Hardware to back up
uh the clients that are coming right
maybe you became huge overnight or over
a week and all of a sudden the 10
servers that you bought three months ago
and took you two months to set up and
wait for them and everything uh you know
you can possibly turn around and order
another 10 and get them configured in 10
minutes
but that is the case in their Cloud
right so that's a win-win situation
there you pay more for more resources
that you need like
the utility bill like electricity but at
the same time you're also making more
money right and when you don't need them
anymore you shut them down and you save
money so this is all these points here
uh are applicable
on-prem and they're applicable in the
cloud however we have much much more
support in the cloud to either
selectively just opt into these um to
these kind of pain points here or these
concerns or
through learning through the program
here that we're talking about
incorporate these features
okay
and
interesting to look at the question of
multi-cloud deployment and
why are is it important to know
how to
deploy something that might
involve more than one Cloud environment
sure so what happens is like anything
you could think of it as maybe you know
banking right you may have all your
money in One Bank lots of people do
right but we all know that you know
historically some financial institutions
haven't fared well and that's you know
the latest one were in Silicon Valley
right where people are having issues
with uh you know taking their money out
and so it's always wise at least to put
you know your eggs in two baskets so to
speak right so in the bank situation you
know you can split your money into Banks
you have more security your security
deposits and everything like that well
it's kind of the same thing in the Cloud
Sure AWS Azure Google Cloud these are
you know the three big entities
um in the in the cloud space but
you never know uh when let's say uh some
data centers might go down a whole a
whole region might go down and you might
want to double up and say you know what
we also want to put some workloads in
the other Cloud just in case to fall
back to uh the other thing is is some
Cloud providers just do things better
or cheaper or simpler right so case in
point let's say you wanted to run a
kubernetes cluster right it's all
Container stuff dealing with kubernetes
well who best than Google right because
they created kubernetes or what if you
wanted to work with you know active
directory
or some AI stuff well Microsoft's really
got a you know a strength there for that
so you might want to say well we've got
these 10 services that we're putting in
the cloud but let's go with you know the
cloud providers that are really the
leaders in those specific Technologies
they all supported they'll all do it but
they'll all do it a little bit
differently and that might be you know a
reason enough for you to say well I like
it better the way Azure is doing it
because it's simpler and it also cheaper
right so and they may have some data
centers in a region closer to your
clients that another cloud provider
doesn't have so knowing that can
facilitate you solving those issues
great thank you for that
um
so I'm going to ask the audience a poll
question and we presume that everyone is
here because you're interested in
becoming a cloud computing professional
that probably means you've looked at
other programs and we're curious to know
why you haven't started a different
certification from a training program up
until this point what is it that you
thought was lacking that kept you from
starting that program
so is it because you can't find a fully
comprehensive program that talks about
all the the services and skills that
Andy described is it because you don't
think you would get practical experience
examples
is it because of the difficulty of
learning from self-paced videos or is it
because it's difficult to find time in
your work schedule as a working
professional
so I'm going to leave this open for just
another five seconds
and we'll close the poll now and here
are the answers so the Andy you can see
that the primary concerns have kept
people from
starting this pathway is
worrying that they wouldn't get
practical experience examples from a
program that would let them prove that
they have these new skills and also
finding
time in their schedule to be able to do
this without disrupting their lives
yeah and that's a common concern right
we see that over and over again and the
nice thing about this program is every
time we get together every time I teach
you life I go through lots of Hands-On
examples and then I'll give you time as
well to go through a series of exercises
which you have documents that showcase
how to go through those steps and we
also have end of chapter projects and
then we also have end of course projects
to validate your learning and stuff like
that and nothing stops you from also
asking questions while I'm doing
demonstrations to further your
understanding so you get hands-on
experience and you get to ask me
questions live as I'm going through
demonstrations with you besides the the
projects I also described yeah that's
that's one of the reasons that Caltech
ctme chose uh simply learning as their
delivery partner Caltech
is of course one of the Premier
educational institutions in the world
develops all sorts of interesting new
technologies and has huge knowledge base
and they've been approached over the
years
by different companies and organizations
with the question can you help our
uh
professionals our employees
to understand these Technologies and use
them so they formed ctme as their
vehicle to provide that training they're
experts in developing industrial line
learning paths that help working
professionals gain those new skills so
that they can use them right away and
they chose to work with simply learn
because we have a online platform an
online platform that is available 24x7
supported 24x7 and you can access it as
a learner anytime that you have time in
your schedule to do your work so other
than the schedule classes with Andy and
the other instructors
which happen on the weekends you can go
onto the system anytime during the week
day night whenever to do your
exercises or to do to watch self-paced
materials to get prepared for the
following these classes
um and the labs and exercises that Andy
described that you're doing
while you're working with him more in
between they're done on the same
platform so you don't have to buy a
system or sign up for
AWS and Azure accounts on your own all
of that the infrastructure is provided
to you
um so Andy in the in the labs you're
going to be able to show some of that
but people can just access the labs and
do their work right online correct
that's correct it's integrated in the
online
LMS system and I can showcase that when
you when you see fit okay
so at the end of this six month period
um
and Andy six months we say you know
people need to to have about 10 hours or
so in their uh work in their week in
order to do the classwork
is it realistic that somebody in six
months can pick up the range of skills
that we talked about
absolutely I've seen it time and time
again I've taught many of these um
courses over the past few years and I've
had people from all sorts of backgrounds
I've even had in one particular case a
musician that knew nothing about it that
came into the course and of course there
was a very large learning curve but this
individual was extremely motivated and
was able to you know procure all the
knowledge necessary to go through the
program and that's really a point I want
to touch on right is you have to be
self-motivated right I'm going to be
showing you everything I know we have
tons of resources here but like Stuart
said you have to invest the 10 to 15
hours a week on your own time without
anybody holding your hand you know using
the materials that are available to you
to practice so you have to practice uh
it's much like you know you can look at
someone training in the gym all day
that's not going to give you any you
know muscles right you're going to have
to actually work this muscle up here
yourself and if you do do that for 10 to
15 hours a day and you attend all the
course is with me I guarantee you that
in six months 10 to 15 hours a week
what did I say you you accidentally said
10 to 15 hours a day I was gonna say
yeah that would be oh yeah of course uh
um a week I apologize yes
I just wanted to make sure that you know
in case anybody was was uh taking it
literally taking it literally
um yes
at the end of the six months you
completed the courses in the project
successfully you earned the certificate
which is issued as you can see by
Caltech
um they hold us accountable for making
sure we deliver their curriculum to
their standards because they're putting
their name behind
the training that you've received you'll
have done
40 Projects or or more in the course of
the courses that you do and
along the
history of the program
you also do a Capstone for a project
if you are in an industry or a job that
requires you to give proof of continuing
education this program offers up to 30
continuing education units from Caltech
so that's a benefit
um you also get membership in the online
Caltech ctme Circle which is an alumni
association
people have taken this type of
Professional Training across different
domains and so you have an ongoing
career networking opportunity through
that and access to their exclusive
events
um you also get involved invited to an
online convocation where you can have
friends and family watch as you get
recognized by name for completing the
program and as someone asked and as I
mentioned before we do provide job
assists which I'll describe in more
detail as we get further further through
here but that will help you find that
next job or that promotion
based on what you've learned
I just want to mention that Caltech we
all know the name I think the California
Institute of Technology is the formal
name of the institution
it is not a California State University
or a member of the University California
system it is a privately run Institution
been around for over 130 years
it does mainly research and graduate
education many people have earned Nobel
prizes for the work they've done at
Caltech many more people who earned
Nobel prizes for work done elsewhere
have come to Caltech to continue that
work so it is one of the greatest
concentrations of Brilliant Minds in the
world has amazing research in
development facilities including the jet
propulsion lab of
NASA where Caltech engineers and
scientists build
the deep space probes and satellites
that NASA launches so it's a amazing
institution one of the top five
universities worldwide on business basis
and that's why having that name on your
resume is
something that will attract attention
catch people's eye
um Andy have you found it
meaningful to to be associated with the
Caltech program and have your students
of your learners found it
yeah absolutely it definitely raises
some eyebrows when people know you're
associated in one way or another with
Caltech right so and also the fact that
you get those 30 continuous education
credits is actually a pretty big deal
there on the previous slide that was
shown yeah so anytime I you know tell
people that I'm teaching for this
program there are you know uh other
other companies that I do business with
they're also extremely impressed by the
name it's got a very rich history and
reputation yeah if if you're a fan of
The Big Bang Theory there's a reason why
they set that at Caltech because
they wanted a show about uh
really brilliant people and like I said
that Caltech is where you find them so
um
the eligibility prerequisites for this
program are very open you can become
entered from a non-programming
background
you can enter with no work experience in
fact you can come right out of high
school as long as you're at least 18
years of age and have your high school
diploma or equivalent
um
so this being this open Andy have you
seen people succeed who have you know
just these minimal uh requirements
I have uh but you need to do some work
okay like I said there's a learning
curve there if you're really coming from
um you know Zero to Hero so to speak
right you you want you want to have some
sort of
um you know self teaching going on for
example you want to know at least uh
uh what a variable is right and
programming what is a variable uh you
want to know in it from a network point
of view what is a network and what is an
IP address and kind of a little bit of
how that works just a little bit uh you
know you got to know a little bit of
those two things just before coming in
you don't need to know how to write a
program you don't need to know how to
set up a network or a router or anything
like that but you know you need to know
if I mentioned the word variable or IP
address or a network or if you're
completely blank on that then there's
going to be more work for you to do to
ramp up so it's always good to know
those kind of things before you come
into the course but that bar is quite
low right so once you get past that bar
which I would imagine most people
already have then picking up the rest of
this stuff is really the same for
everybody because everybody you know
coming in usually is new to the cloud
and there's a lot of things you can
leverage from your knowledge of maybe
already working in the industry anyways
for those that are completely new of
course it's going to be more work than
than somebody who already has been in
the industry through four years but
the payoff is massive yeah
thank you for that
so let's talk about how this program
prepares you and I'm just looking in the
chat we have a question
incidentally
um Maureen asks looking at another
program that the simply learned Caltech
ctme coding boot camp and what would be
the difference and why would you choose
the cloud boot camp over the coding boot
camp we're going to talk about the
coding boot or the cloud bootcamp here
and Maureen this should give you some
idea of
the difference here and what we focus on
in the cloud computing boot camp that
would be different from coding and the I
imagine
somebody who's looking at the coding
boot camp is looking at becoming a
developer and
that's an aspect of cloud computing but
that's not the be-all end all of cloud
computing right
that's right so you know you've got more
of a
kind of your your your telescoping into
really a a specific sort of set of
Technologies development but eventually
that program or whatever language you
you're deciding to learn or multiple
languages that program you're writing
eventually has to be deployed somewhere
right now yeah you can deploy it on your
laptop you can deploy it on a server
that's running in your company but I
guarantee you eventually that that
application was going to be run you know
90 chance it's eventually going to be
run on the cloud okay so how do you
actually take that application and put
it on the cloud for you know scalable
fault tolerance highly available
architectures how
um do you debug it how do you look at
its logs how do you even continue
development of that application with the
language that you learned in the cloud
so that's going to give you
a different side of uh look at how to
code in a completely different
environment right instead of coding on
your laptop maybe you'll be clothing on
a machine that's in the cloud and your
integrated development environment will
be automatically updated for you in the
cloud instead of you having to update it
all the time you know on your laptop so
that you know the skills that you
learned from a coding point of view
those don't change like learning all the
Syntax for Python and the modules and
all that that's not going to change in
the cloud but how you deploy an
architect that application the cloud is
definitely going to be different than
on-premise so yeah that's those are the
takeaways
program
kind of as we've Illustrated here
takes you step by step through the the
skills and knowledge that you need for
cloud computing so that at each stage
you have more knowledge and more
preparation for the next step so we talk
about the induction session that's
basically a couple of hours online
getting oriented to how to use the
platform what the curriculum is basics
of cloud computing in terms of
just a rough thumbnail of what what it
is and what the aspects are but that
takes you into the first formal class
which is uh AWS Cloud fundamentals can
you kind of talk us through how this
staircase Works Andy
sure so the first Cloud fundamentals one
is more like the view of the forest
before going into
um you know individual trees so what I
mean by that is we break up all the
services and categories like networking
compute Etc
and we kind of talk about the different
services in every one of those
categories so if you if you want to run
a machine in the cloud we call that a
virtual machine well what's that service
called in AWS or what's that service
called in you know Asia or later on we
also have the fundamentals here so you
get you know you get a wide view of all
those services and what categories
and after that that's a quite a a small
course in comparison to the others it's
about a two weekend course after that
you go into designing applications
and architectures in AWS and this is
where again we will revisit the same
services and more but we go into depth
now should I say what are the features
of all those Services how do they
interact with other services and how
does that build those effective
architectures I was referring to before
okay once you've got all that
you'll you'll notice that once you go to
azure
you're not really alert you're not
relearning from scratch
because I would say 30 to 40 percent of
what you learned in AWS will also be
applicable in Asia because it's the
principles that you're going to
recognize and you'll say oh it's not
called you know X here it's called Y in
in Azure right so the names will be
different there'll be some
um you know architectural patterns that
might be a little bit different because
the features are different but you'll
find yourself more on Common Ground so
you're not going to have to go through
that you know immense learning curve
once again for every new cloud provider
and that's for other Cloud providers as
well in your path you know after even
simpler you'll notice that there's a lot
of reoccurring principles from one cloud
provider to the next
and once you've moved on you've looked
at
AWS you've looked at Azure you've
learned how to
um
approach problems from the architectural
standpoint
you start looking at how to deploy
um with the CI and CD
um
pipelines yeah um
then you get to the final module in the
program which is a Capstone project
um we have a slide on the Capstone
project but can you can briefly talk
about why this is an important aspect of
the program
well the Capstone project basically you
know it's it's it's you saying well I
can swim on my own now right you don't
have to you know have a lifeguard there
anymore uh I can do laps in the pool I I
need to set up this project here are all
the steps these are all the requirements
rather and based on you know the
previous six months I'm able to now uh
know how to go get the information put
it together based on all of the demos
the Hands-On you did previously in all
the previous courses you can now see the
big picture and you can now drill down
into you know uh the specific features
of every service that you need to to put
together let's say an application that
deals with Healthcare data okay and
deploy that across in multiple regions
right and have a failover database and
so everything kind of comes together and
it allows you to
also put that on your resume and say hey
I was able to do such and such
um Capstone project the word Capstone
really now is more of an industry
standard right Capstone really means hey
you were able to put something together
by yourself right with minimal
instructions right it's not a you know a
to-do list of screenshots on how to do
things it's someone saying
these are the stakeholders this is what
the stakeholder wants put it together in
the cloud
yep thank you for that
Capstone of course comes from
in architecture when you're building an
arch you put the
vinyl stone at the top of the arch which
is the Capstone and so this is the final
piece of your program final proof of
your your completion in the electives
which are included in the cost of the
program
um you can take them or or not as you
choose that's why we call them electives
but
we know a few of them here one is the
cloud computing master classes from
Caltech instructors and faculty who come
in and talk about new developments in
the industry or case studies that type
of things that adds a lot of
interest and value
kind of flavor to the program right
yeah there's some mentoring sessions
there there's also uh support and um we
have a a community channel that you can
send questions to that's monitored on a
weekly basis so you can have an answer
before the next course
um and if you have any
um we have 24 7 support as well if
you're dealing with any issues on the
platform so there's there's a lot of
support there outside of the classroom
opportunities come to office hours and
and talk with your instructor
um one-on-one
um
do you cover a number of different tools
and platforms there are dozens upon
dozens of different
tools
features and
each of the platforms so we couldn't put
them all on a slide but you know the
idea here is
that in the course of the program you
learn
what the different
Cloud functions are what the pieces are
you need for a cloud deployment
and what they're called in the different
platforms and how to use them right
and that's correct right so all of these
Services by themselves uh of course by
themselves they do have some value right
for example a database if we talk about
a database there's there's a database
here on the left called Amazon dynamodb
which is a nosql database now that's
great you have a nosql database but uh
we go through you know what what isn't
as a nosql database and why would you
want it over a traditional SQL database
like MySQL let's say right and by itself
that doesn't really give you uh very
much because you might want to have a
web application that interfaces with
that database right so you need another
service that runs a web application so
that would be the elastic
compute cloud service in Amazon which is
basically how we run a virtual machine
so you need to connect those two
together and so this is where we're
going is is you're going to come up with
an architecture that
conveys the bigger picture right I need
something to run a web application I
need someone for you know storing my
backups I need something for my
transactional database
etc etc and you kind of plug them all in
together in a really resilient
architecture yeah and and again we're
doing that on the live virtual platform
which is
um
your opportunity to do the work Hands-On
and use the tools rather than just hear
about them
um as Andy described the Capstone
project
is you know your chance to demonstrate
your project without somebody meant you
know um holding your hand you have the
opportunity to meet with your instructor
weekly to make sure you're on track but
they're not going to do the project for
you it's something that you do as an
individual project that shows off your
new skills so as Andy describes it might
be a health care problem where you get a
set of requirements and need to build
the end-to-end solution
um but at the end of the process along
with all the other projects you've done
in the course are in your online
portfolio you can show them off the
people uh as part of your your job
search or your justification for getting
that promotion so it's an extremely
valuable part of the program
um
here are some of the types of problems
you might find in Capstone or other
projects
um
and he talked about the healthcare one
you might build a kind of
A Primitive version of Netflix or you
might build uh the kind of thing the
restaurant chain would use to support
all their Outlets or you might build an
e-commerce site in each of these cases
you get a full
specification of what the project has to
do and what tools you need to use and
you get the environment on which you can
build it so
um
that's a it makes it a realistic
practice session
the
simply learned platform and the
community that we operate gives you an
ecosystem of support So as I mentioned
we're responsible to Caltech we're
delivering this program
um we therefore have a program manager
who interacts with Folks at Caltech and
make sure that we're meeting their
standards when you join the program you
join on a given date
along with another set of people that
become your cohort and your cohort has a
success manager assigned to it help all
of you succeed
um
together
your instructors of course are helping
you with the individual coursework
draw on support from your fellow
Learners your peers and the curriculum
the resources the system itself are all
designed to maximize your chances of
success so there's all of these
different elements that are helping make
sure you stay on track and ensure that
you succeed in this program so
we are very proud that we have a very
high completion rate
and this is where I'm going to ask Andy
to go ahead
show us
a live demo of the learning management
system just so you can see what the
features are and where
the different learning tools are so
indeed should be able to go ahead and do
that
if you're not
let me
let me make sure you have the ability
privileged to do that
okay you got it
I can see it on one of my screens I
can't see it on the other one
where did I go
huh that's strange
uh so I'm sharing their Caltech cloud
computing boot camp web page here okay
everybody see that
okay fantastic
uh so once you log in to Simply learn of
course you don't have a username and
password yet you'd be brought to this
page over here and this is kind of that
slide
represented in a different way where you
have the different courses right you had
the introduction which is a two three
hour orientation section and then you
start with the cloud fundamentals and so
on and so forth right so let's say we
were both doing the designing
applications and architecture in AWS you
would click that
and you would be brought to all the
material the learning management system
for that specific course right so what
happens here is we have a self
learning section now the self-learning
section is all about if you look here on
the on the right all of the chapters all
of the lessons that we're going to be
doing live together but you have a side
uh inventory a library if you will of
video so if you wanted to learn
something about databases on lesson six
let's say we were doing that next
Saturday I would tell you in advance
please review lesson six on databases
and you could just go and find out what
you know RDS is part one and then you'll
have the video on relational databases
which are
SQL databases that are managed in AWS
right so you go through all of that
of course by the time you get to a live
training then you'll have a good
understanding you can ask me more
informed questions right instead of what
does RDS stand for you'd be asking more
you know evolved questions there because
you were more prepared so this is what
I'm talking about you're going to invest
10 to 15 hours a week
in order to
and be prepared and be able to learn
more because you'll be able to ask
better questions right so we've got the
self-learning we also got the live
classes which of course right now are
not running in this case but you could
see some past classes here so these are
some of the past classes that I've run
and at the end of the course within
about 24 hours you get a recording of it
which is great right so sometimes you
know we live busy lives we might not be
able to handle the entire four-hour you
know class that specific day you have to
a family event whatever so you can
always refer back to it but not even for
that even if you have attended the the
class it's always nice and when
everything is New To You Right to go
back and slowly
you know and kind of reverse and go back
just like a YouTube video right so it
gives you a really great way to um kind
of reinforce the learning all right so
that usually happens within 24 hours
after the course
we have assessments
so these are tests that you would do
after the course
okay
um these courses here and by the way
those videos are not the same videos
that are on simply learns YouTube
channel
uh I saw the question there show up so
these are tests that you would take
after you have to pass one of these
tests with I believe 70 percent we'll
confirm that in a second and so if you
don't pass the first test you can do the
second test here you just need to get
over
um you know 70 and every course has
projects so you have to finish one of
these three projects so here's an
example of a project that asks you to
configure
a mySQL database
to connect to a web server and then set
up a monitoring solution so you would
download the PDF and you would kind of
go through the more elaborate steps that
would help you but you would need to you
know actually do this project so there's
less hand holding here get lots of
students that ask me for help and I
offer it and you know you should read
these projects on a weekly basis and as
you're learning new material asking more
informed questions and at the end of the
in all those weeks you get to do one of
these these three projects to pass this
course and one of these two tests over
here and once you do that
right uh you get to unlock your
certificate right so right now this
certificate will not be unlocked because
I didn't do one of those two
um you know tests which again is 70 pass
and I did not complete the one of those
three projects but if I had then you
would be able to download your
certificate for that particular course
out of the stack of courses in that one
cohort here okay
now the other thing that's really great
is we have practice labs
and you can right away just launch a lab
in AWS and it'll allow you very simply
to uh the first time of course I might
take a minute to load this but it'll
give you credentials and a link in order
to
open up an AWS console right so let me
just quickly go here paste this over
here
all right
and I will need my username
copy that
okay
and so this is basically the login
prompt for
doing work in the clouds for AWS right
so let me log in there maybe get a
little bit bigger for us
and right now say hello to the AWS
console this is the very first look on
how AWS looks like I'm sure it looks
intimidating to you right it did for me
for sure but this is where I come in
show you
everything I know about AWS and so this
is going to be your second home
eventually okay and by the time you're
finished with me you guys are going to
be experts so for example if I wanted to
create a machine a virtual machine
in AWS it'd be very simple
I would come here and I would identify
would teach you what services is is you
know responsible for creating a virtual
machine and I mentioned before it was
ec2 elastic
compute Cloud right so I'm going to
click on that
and then of course this
view looks even more intimidating
because there's so many links and
features and of course all the services
have kind of a page that's intimidating
like this but this is what this course
is all about there's this kind of
demystifying and giving you the
confidence to navigate all this right so
just think of the way you felt the first
time you saw Excel or word with all
those buttons right
but now you're feeling more confident
with those right it's going to be the
same thing so don't worry so I can just
simply launch an instance
launch a virtual machine call it
whatever I want maybe I'll call it you
know my web server
call whatever you want and you can pick
whatever
operating system that you want so we
have many different Linux flavors
Microsoft even Linux has a specific
flavor in AWS that has some pre-built
software in there so we'll pick that
you can pick different kinds of machines
that are more powerful than others so
there's many many different kinds of
machines again this is all on the cloud
I don't have to
call order wait for the shipment
configure it in my data center these are
all machines that I can just simply pick
for example this one here has eight CPUs
15 gigs of RAM so you pick the one that
best suits your needs and you pay for
only what you use right so I'm going to
use a little small one here that only
has one CPU and one gig of memory
because we're not really deploying
anything here
and there's many many settings which you
know this is not the the place to talk
about every feature I just want to show
you how easy it is to just create a
virtual machine in the cloud using the
default
uh the default settings and a couple of
extra ones here so you can actually
allow uh you know HTTP traffic HTTP
secure traffic through the firewall if
you want to if your web application
needs that right you can pick the kind
of storage your disk space that you want
So if you think you're going to need for
whatever reason
30 gigs of space
right
you can just say that's what you want I
mean that's the cloud it's completely
elastic it'll give you what you want
okay you don't have to order a disk it's
just there
so I'm just going to leave at 8 but just
to Showcase you know you can just ask
for for what you want right and you have
many different uh advanced
features as well that we're going to go
through in the class but one that's very
interesting that I want to talk to you
about
is this section here that you can just
automate the installation of uh software
deploy a web page let's say in a server
you can do all this uh over here very
quickly by just taking a script that
you've already written right now we're
not going to go through this now but
let's say I'm a developer and I want to
deploy a little web page on a server but
I don't want to log into the machine
and actually do this manually I want it
to be done automatically for me so I
paste this is like a to do do this for
me once you boot up the machine please
because I don't want to do this manually
so it's going to go and install all this
software create a web page for me which
will be my web application for this
demonstration and then I could even say
how many instances how do I want 10 do I
want to launch 10 machines
do I want to launch a hundreds do I want
to launch just one I mean can you see
the power of that
I could launch a hundred machines
just like that if I want to on the cloud
you can't just simply go to a number
like that on premise what if you only
have 50 machines right so I'm going to
launch one machine here
and
I'm not going to create a key pair oh I
might say create I'll just say my key
here just it's just for security to
create a key to uh maybe SSH or
something
I'm going to pick a network oh
unfortunately the lab doesn't have a
network that's probably because it puts
me in the wrong region
um you see here all these regions these
are all the regions all across the world
that have data centers in AWS so I could
say you know what I'm not going to go to
Oregon I'm going to go to North Virginia
right and North Virginia might be closer
to my customers
okay so in this case here now it's going
to bring me to the page to Launch
that machine in Norwich Virginia
and I'll just very quickly just uh kind
of do the steps over again here with uh
do the same thing I did before I
apologize for that the the
lab the cons
yeah now it's okay I'm gonna just edit
this make sure I have a network yet so
we're okay now it was before they didn't
create a network in the other uh
and the other region for us I'm just
going to launch the instance now
create my little key to log into after
if I please
and off we go
we're going to launch this instance
and you can see here that it's
automating everything for us right now
of course there's many things I didn't
explain on purpose right because we're
not in the corset and we had that little
hiccup with the other region but all it
is is you saying you want a machine
you want this storage you want it in
this network and you might have created
other networks right and here's a little
script to install everything I want and
it's automatically going to launch a
virtual machine with your application on
it so I can actually View
my machine over here
called my virtual machine and you could
see right now it's actually pending
right it says pending here it's being
provisioned for me so it's found the
place that's found the rack with the
machine in a data center in North
Virginia and it says you want that fine
I'm going to give it to you I'm going to
install the software that you wanted on
that script and once it's ready as it
says it's running over here already it's
in green
make this a little bit bigger
okay now I'm ready to go I will get here
at the bottom a little IP address or a
little public DNS name over here and I
could paste that
in the browser and I would be able to
see my website once it's you know ready
so it's actually doing some stuff in the
background now but just I'll stop there
just to show you that you know it's
super easy to provision a virtual
machine in the cloud using defaults
there and you can install anything you
want on that virtual machine and connect
to it just like you would in an on-prem
Data Center
so going back to the uh LMS system here
right so again these labs are good for
eight hours and then they get kind of
reset so you don't you can do no harm
don't worry you're not going to break
anything on the cloud the Cloud's not
going to come falling down on you right
you do what you want in there uh and
then it'll get reset okay we have our
community over here
as well in the LMS system that allows
you to you know we'll create one for the
specific class
you could come in here and you can ask
questions and I'll go in there respond
and if ever you run into any questions
that you need to ask open up any support
tickets we have the help over here
and there's always somebody here to help
you I actually had to open up a ticket
yesterday I had an issue with my labs
and they they helped me out with it I
think it was three hours it was it was
all technically set up for me so
proof that it works
and that's pretty much what I have for
my demonstration there Stuart
all right thank you so much I appreciate
that you kind of covered everything that
um
is within that environment I'm going to
go ahead and go back to the
go back to our
presentation
as I mentioned before
we are accountable to Caltech for
delivery of this program so our program
manager answers to Rick Hefner who is
the executive director of Caltech CT
as well as John wetch Who is the
program director for the cloud computing
program cpme and these are the folks who
make sure our curriculum
matches the Caltech CTE standards and
that we're delivering it to their
standards as well so
these are people who as I said interact
with
industry with other organizations and
make sure that their programs meet the
needs of what people industry are hiring
for so
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
and we're going to ask
Lewis to
comment a little bit about the diversity
of students within the programs we have
in this program you can come in without
work experience but a lot of people are
working professionals
who have who are at different companies
how does that
enrich the learning environment in your
classes at least when you have people
who can
share experiences from different
companies
well it's it's great because you get
different types of questions right
someone coming from a financial
background working for a bank might have
different concerns than someone working
in let's say e-commerce or something
like that and the other thing it allows
you to also you're going to get to know
each other quite well over the weeks
together and so it creates a good kind
of networking amongst the Learners right
so you can connect let's say on LinkedIn
afterwards with each other and that'll
give you actually you know kind of a leg
up in the industry you can have you know
you kind of become colleagues so to
speak in the classroom so I've seen some
people kind of help each other out for
openings and things like that as well so
it's kind of a win-win situation
excellent
um
we have a couple of the testimonials
that you can find on our program web
page and we'll be sharing a link to that
but uh you have Jorge who talked about
um
being able to use or leverage this
program to move into a different domain
in cloud computing and double his salary
which is kind of a
a pretty good outcome
we have uh Mario who is able to put
himself in a position where now there
are recruiters coming after him to
Place him in new jobs so those are great
positions to be in we hope that we can
add you and our audience to our learner
Seth and maybe have one of your uh
success stories here on our website so
as I have mentioned go into more detail
about these job assist services
so for us Learners we have a partnership
with Talent Incorporated Talent
Incorporated provides you access to the
premium job portal that they run uh
gives you some exclusive job
opportunities also gives you a way to
look at new job opportunities in a
completely confidential way without
revealing your job search to your
current employer
I think the other parts of the service
are at least as important which is
resume review and rewrite
um it helps you prepare your resume to
pass through the automated AI Bots that
will filter it against job descriptions
employers give
but it'll also they'll also make sure
that your resume is still attractive to
the human beings who will see it later
and then the one-on-one interview prep
is extremely valuable because as you
know you have to pass a lot of different
types of interviews
order to get that next job the phone
screens technical interviews and
cultural fit company culture interviews
are also
things you can practice one-on-one learn
how to AC to those interview types
so that set of services is available to
you for six months after you earn your
certificate
um that means that for six months after
you've got the qualification from
Caltech ctme you have access to these
services to help in your job search
so
um
the next cohort will start
the past first August so the induction
and the reduction will be coming up I
believe on the eight
which is today and again on the 15th but
the next cohort of classes starts on the
25th of September 25th of September is
the start date you can take the two hour
induction session before that and the
fees for the program are nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine dollars
um
be finance and equal monthly
installments of 880 dollars
and to get started you would contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net we say
that limited seats are available because
this is not a massively online open
course this is not a course where
um since you're just looking at
self-study materials we can accommodate
as many people as sign up
because of the live interaction live
classes we have to limit the cohort
sizes to about 25 to 30 individuals so
that the instructors have sufficient
time in order to devote
individual attention to each learner so
if you are interested in getting started
in the 25th September class sessions
please contact us right away and get
your place reserved
so at this point
I just want to ask a quick question are
you interested
in enrolling
in this program
let me start that Poll for you
in a second
we're just going to leave this open for
about 10 or 15 seconds so yes or no
question
and I think uh numbers have stopped
changing I'll just end the poll and
share the result
so almost 80 percent of you are
interested in getting started that is
excellent
let me
share with you
how to do that
and the enrollment steps are extremely
straightforward you email it us at ask
us at simplylearn.net
we will review your qualifications again
the prerequisites are very very simple
for this program and we'll contact you
with an admission offer
um the point once you accept it you can
get started
so
real quick question for those of you who
said you were interested
how soon would you like to do it are you
looking at the September cohort maybe in
October November or are you looking
further down the road
and I will close this poll
in three
two
one
so about 60 percent of you are looking
at starting
maybe not September but right thereafter
and for those of you looking further
down the road we recommend that you also
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
um in order to make sure that you find
out about future cohorts and get any
last questions answered and
on that note it's time for us to take
your questions
so
Russia if you would like to to help take
some of the questions and answers
no
so I can see that ritika and Felix have
the same questions like what is the cost
of this course
I think we have already revealed that
right
so the pricing of this course so we can
go back to that slide uh is uh
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars and uh yeah we also have like
financing available as low as you know
880 per month
I hope that answers your question uh
Felix and rithika
uh
uh user bubble Allah
does this course also cover azure
and
what can you say uh Lewis about the
balance between AWS and Azure in this
program
well there's uh three Azure courses
versus two AWS courses so uh I can't
speak for the length in terms of
material or the weeks for Asia because I
don't teach those ones but I mean it's
it's it's essentially a 50 50 split
there almost
okay
um and
we have a question uh Phil asks how
competitive is this uh
certification uh on the job market
so this we have a pretty good track
record you can ask our learning
Consultants by emailing us but they will
help you with statistics on placements
rate at which people find work after
completing this course
and we're extremely proud of of our rate
um
we have a question from an anonymous
attendee I'm considering a move into the
tech space
um
where would you compare cloud computing
skills versus data or business and
analytics skills as a entry point into
Tech
business analytics yeah
well you'd have to give me maybe a
little bit more you know
meet on that question in terms of
business analysis I mean one business
analysis will be one of one of the
things you're going to do as a as a
cloud architect right you're going to be
analyzing the business needs of of
whatever stakeholders are in that
company
um and then how to translate them to
architecture right how to do the same
thing you would have done on-prem but
what are the services that you need to
know in an Azure or in AWS to facilitate
that where the architectures uh I I
think you know that's one of the aspects
of a cloud architect so it's more than
just business analysis It's actually an
analyzing but also implementing right
and as compared to data analytics data
science
is there well data analysis is
is there is there a clear distinction
um um or way to choose between
that field versus cloud computing or the
you know apples and oranges kind of
no data science right I mean all of that
stuff is done in the cloud right there's
many services dealing with uh you know
data warehousing business analytics
machine learning algorithms to extract
business intelligence you know from the
from vast amount of data that's you know
probably stored in like a a data Lake
and so it's just one aspect of the cloud
like I said all the Technologies you've
ever heard about are already in the
cloud they're all encompassing okay so
you can decide to become a you know a
data analysis analyst or a Java
programmer outside of the cloud right
but all those things are available in
the cloud at a grander scale
got a question from Edison who asks if
the certificate indicates
the number of hours of instruction in
the program and the
the answer to that is that um
the certificate if you add if you're
asked or if somebody asks Caltech they
will answer
that this program reflects a certain
number of hours based on the ceu so the
CEUs are
direct reflection of the number of hours
of instruction provided
yes this does actually give you a
a metric on that
um
and we've had a number of people ask if
the recording of this session will be
shared which it will as I mentioned or
as a as Russia mentioned at the
beginning we will be sending you
um
a uh I think the program recording at
the at the beginning uh
once we
finish the session you'll receive that
by email
take a look here if we have other
questions
have
I think I can see uh from Carl Kiran uh
what is the pricing to join from the UK
I think has been asked recently
yeah um and the answer to that is this
this particular Cloud boot camp is
designed for U.S Learners although we do
have an edition of the cloud Tech
Caltech cloud
postgraduate program which is available
worldwide
so that covers a similar curriculum
designed for people who are outside the
North American time zones
so if you take a look at our
program web page or if you um
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
we will be able to
provide you information with the program
as well
Nicholas says I'm interested in cyber
security but Cloud also seems
interesting
how do the two Fields relate to each
other
and can you offer uh Nicola any
guidance on
one over the other
yeah so security is a shared
responsibility model in the cloud
it'd be nice if the cloud did all of
your security from start to end but
unfortunately that's not how it works
you also will need to uh secure your
data and your applications now sometimes
you have very little to do depending on
the types of services you opt in for and
other times you'll have more to do but
you'll always have something to do so
that's why
I say there's a shared responsibility
model now of course there's a wide array
of services from you know firewalls to
intrusion detection
um systems and everything in between and
that's more we do cover security of
course in the course and we do have
um many services that we kind of go over
uh in security but it's not a you know
full-blown cyber security course right
that is its own specialization in AWS it
has its own certificate and we only
cover that at the high level what we
will cover in this course from a
security point of view is firewalls uh
at the VM levels we'll cover also
something called the network access
control lists that work at subnet levels
that's about where we stop for security
and encryption encryption keys
you know encrypting data at rest
encrypting data in transit that's about
where we go in this course for security
okay excellent
um and I am going to put into the chat
right now by the way the program home
page URL
people can see some more information
about the program as well as the email
address ask us
at simplylearn.net
okay and we're over time so I'm afraid
that's all the time we have for
questions
um I want to thank everybody
being here Stuart can I just uh can I
just add can I just uh there was
somebody that asked if you wanted to see
the web they wanted to see the web page
that I had deployed in the virtual
machine could I just very quickly show
that yes please
okay I'm just going to share here
my screen
and uh basically bring that up
so what I did is once it was up and
running
I just copy copy this uh you could copy
the IP address or the DNS name here come
to another browser paste it up here and
this would be the web page that's being
served from that
virtual machine in the cloud very simple
just Welcome to Cloud Computing you
click on this it's a link that goes to
Wikipedia I believe yeah okay so that's
deployed on an Apache web server that
was deployed in the script there that we
that we looked at
all right thank you for the appreciate
you showing that
and I'm going to uh at this point Thank
you for being so generous with your your
time and your knowledge Andy
Rasha thank you thank you for helping us
get this presentation underway
thank you everybody
thank you thank you everyone for joining
thank you so much Stuart uh for helping
me head through the session
and thank you to everyone who's here in
the audience today we really appreciate
you taking your time out of your work
schedule or your uh home schedule to
join us learn about the cloud computing
career field and we hope that we can
welcome you into the Learning Community
with Caltech and simply learn
um and that concludes our webinar for
today so again thank you so much hope to
see you all soon bye bye
foreign